there you go
hey look what kind you text me no white
glasses
better and make security wear black
gloves the orange look made me so mad
would have went to jail before I went
out in that I'll be home for a Norse
game Kim Kardashian and Kanye West might
not be married anymore but yay isn't
afraid to let Kim know how he feels when
it comes to her fashion choices we have
different views sometimes during the
latest episode of Hulu's the Kardashians
the skims founder reads a text she
received from her ex while she was in
Milan for the Prada fashion show in
February and let's just say he wasn't
exactly loving Kim's looks no white
glasses the orange look made me so mad
while we're here in Milan Kanye has the
kids at home and he can't help himself
but this isn't the first time the rapper
has critiqued Kim's ensembles oh I don't
care on season one of the family's new
reality series Kim revealed one of the
not so nice things he said amid their
split he told me my career's over and
then he showed me a picture of Marge
Simpson wearing something similar the
kkw beauty founder was referring to this
outfit she rocked while being honored at
wsj Magazine's innovator Awards last
October and Marge Simpson well yeah it's
exactly who you're thinking The Simpsons
family matriarch I don't know how you're
gonna top that at the time the reality
star publicly praised the 45 year old
musician for his impact on her style
telling the outlet quote Kanye will
always be the most inspirational person
to me I always know his heart Flash
Forward to season two and Kanye was back
at it but this time Kim says it's all in
good fun we can laugh about things we
like or don't like no matter how crazy
things are sometimes we're always gonna
be family and I'll text him back and be
like you know you have been wearing
those boots for a long time so when
you're ready to change your outfit let
me know and then you can have advice on
mine
[Music]